[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et la misère il ya huit arbres en coin
30e timbale l'histoire ont passé un cap
on va voir si vous regardez votre tiges
suis pas sûr on va voir toutefois on
peut c'est une émission qui mêle médias
d'arca et surtout de danse en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on en est encore
à pas danser ça fait deux jours de tollé
non mais c'est vrai en tout cas on est
sûr qu'on n'est pas nos émissions de
mathématiques ça c'est sûr cerino vais
me rappeler des études vous avez fait
vous moi j'étais expertise comptable
d'accord fonds table quant à dont des
chiffres ce père this book exploitants
c'est encore plus fort comme nous avons
montré fort hanche et donc on calcule
vous êtes très fort je faire des
meilleurs aujourd'hui sur le paf
au québec ça se voit un connard jeu
c'est lundi que les prennent la
différence de taille entre boeufs nés
bürki et faustine bollaert
alors si mes souvenirs au cp sont bons
180 cas de -104 ça fait vingt donc 20
centimètres d'écart et je me suis
toujours demandé pourquoi j'avais des
soucis sur ma fiche de paye et bien j'ai
compris parce que pour celles à 1984 cm
- 100 104 cm ça fait 18 centimes est
trop tard
c'est un mètre 66 ils sont trompés alors
ça vaut fischer c'est un mètre soixante
sadok encore mais aux médias quand matt
corchia est bon mais savez vous en
sortez toujours ça va il ya quelques
jours nous avions ce plateau fabien
lecoeuvre qui refond son ami douchka on
m'appelait de dunga qui chanter les
tubes destinés à 2 3 me qui donne l des
mois pour la danse on garde la cadence
on connaissait tous les tubes 7,3 à fond
la musique aux lakers à fond le
romantisme
c'est fou quand qu'on est une chanson
comme ça ça fait plaisir
et donc quand tous les deux se
retrouvent c'est comme deux amis qui se
retrouvent ils veulent toujours raconter
des anecdotes qui les passionne eu assez
dont nous on se fout complètement
les séries une fois de plus je voudrais
pas faire semblant non vous n'avez pas
forcément monitorer mais moi c'est ce
que vous pensez alors encore une fois
j'ai décidé de vous pénétrez je parle
votre cerveau bien sûr je vais traduire
ce que vous pensiez quand fabien
lecoeuvre raconter ses souvenirs disney
c'est le nouveau anodine side
je chante mes aventures de disney de
l'époque qu'on a traversé avec fabien
avait perdu tic et tac
non mais il est sérieux lui tic et tac
la prochaine fois il va me parler d'eux
quand il a joué au bowling avec roxy
rookie ça on était parti avant avec tik
et tak et puis on les avait perdus dans
le traîneau et on les avait oubliés
l'entrée d'eau qu'on a un million de
personnes qui regardent et le gars il me
parle de deux écureuils qui l'a oublié
dans un trade au fait d arrêter tous les
traîneaux bon c'est sur lui je vais
l'envoyer rejoindre le cimetière de la
dark avec christophe carrière et rachid
arhab
c'est vrai j'ai fait le père noël bon ça
suffit il faut rentrer chez toi
maintenant à thoune
[Musique]
les groupes enfin bon bien sûr alors il
est temps que ça se voyait pas ça se
voyait lui se cacher derrière lui se
cacher des mais je n'ai pas soit honnête
oui tout bas les masques maintenant oui
parce que je me sens mieux après non il
m'a chopé dans les loges
alors autant que là si tu ne regardes
pas eu le courage de voir cyril voilà
oui il m'a chopé en disant j'ai pas
tellement apprécié le fait que pendant
mon anecdote tu mets carte un petit peu
si ça ne t'intéresse pas ce que je
raconte c'était très maladroit donc
juste voilà fabien la prochaine fois on
va voir ses rides et il lui avoue tout
cas
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il fait peur en apprenant qu'ils vous
disent ah vous voilà en tout cas moi je
suis sûr qu'il va vous le diront oui oui
il me fait quand même un buzzer fabien
je m'en bats les couilles et fabien lui
ce qu'il fera d'autres dans le groupe
barka dont on y jouait j'embrasse aussi
rakim engueuler par jour à l'aide alors
il est temps que tous vos réactions
c'est l'anecdote
alors chaque semaine vous savez que vous
décerner la meilleure van geel dans
l'émission alors voici les nommer pour
ce lancement je ne suis pas fait chier
cyril hanouna pour savane fruitière
jamais sans fin d'époque style mais je
crois qu'un peu pourquoi je sais pas
mais je m'y attendais pas je vais aussi
bien c'est pas parce que on mange des
abricots qu'on n'aime pas la balle à
l'adversaire
matthieu delormeau pour savane toujours
plein d'amitié
je trouvais que j'emmenais était très
très beau et d'éclat ni fait un peu
italien et les îles et chic il ne sent
pas un vrai politique de tout le monde
mette à personne
et jean michel maire qui doit faire une
déclaration d'amour et qui choisit
isabelle morini bosc et vas-y maliennes
attaquent la son père lachaise
[Applaudissements]
je pense que c'est brico c'est vous
abricot merci benjamin est venu fanni
fanny elle revient à les tentures kanger
reviendra la semaine prochaine quand
vous arrêtez pas très bon on verra la
semaine prochaine à istanbul jours oui
ben il va écouter ça va aller à gala
face à galatasaray d'accords cassés pas
votre sim jeu sur wii mais les mariés
oui bah oui mais comme ça aussi mais
qu'ils tombent aux jeunes familles et
des 15 tours suis choquée mais à quel
poste
alors ça change rien il va vous péter la
gueule mais je te le dis c'est vrai il a
priori c'est qu'aucune aucune relation
de marche à distance aucune par monsieur
couture et la personne arrêtée bien sûr
que ça m'a vite avec une meuf qui habite
hyper un an avant oui ah tu lis ma bien
sûr je marchais
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
mardi soir on assiste un moment très
choqué mais aussi tous les gens devant
leur télé alors j'ai décidé de remettre
les awards du moment le plus sexy de ces
dernières semaines vous allez voir ya
plusieurs moments sexy les nommés sont
fanning et chats et kelly b2b qui en
dansant ont participé à la fonte de la
banquise
[Musique]
heureusement pour assécher la planète
on a régime verdez et benjamin castaldi
[Applaudissements]
et cyril hanouna car on a tous envie de
revoir le moment où ils regardent le cul
plus de matthieu delormeau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
savoir que telle et dire tout à l'heure
et je sais que vous allez choisir la
dernière vous connais j'ai ça bien sûr
ces dernières années trop faire dans le
tabac vous avez votre propre langage
hamas de dark à doha sera et autres nick
sa grand mère pas étonnant votre nom
soit cité dans les prochaines
candidatures possibles pour la
présidentielle 2022 et chaque jour
rempli des thèmes très élégant alors
pour la phrase la plus élégante de la
semaine les nommés sont
[Musique]
cyril hanouna pour sa phrase en hommage
aux esthéticiennes 80 centièmes et moi
je trouve qu'il devrait faire sur vous
quand vous êtes chanter des
esthéticiennes oui vous avez arraché des
poils de cul gratuitement pour sa phrase
en hommage à tous les gastronomes cm cit
group rtl m6 régulièrement on a des
indications de la direction qui dit si
vous voyez tel message s'est fait
surtout ne cliquez pas annoncé comment
ça c'est moi que ces suspects et cyril
hanouna pour sa phrase en hommage aux
pompiers
cooper de ce ca vous enlève la douleur
sa ville allait déposer les très graves
le mec je me sais capable de vous dire
comment ça marche mais beaucoup
d'hôpitaux puisqu'ils sont spécialisées
dans les grandes villes de nitra y avait
clamé sa marche autour d'elle fait
aucune
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la plus élégante c'est autre chose c'est
le temps robin il attendait celui que
plus tacler ses collègues cette semaine
le tabac et le suspense est connexe et
j'en suis certain alors qui sera le 36e
vous avez été très marquée par la
terrible j'ai été très marqué par la
belle et bien écoutez le 30e tabac de
l'histoire ne touche pas à mon poste et
c'est de pire en pire
mais alors danser et moi ce que tu te
sens mais ma page d'un balai dans le cul
donc bah c'est pas grave tu parles vous
avez déjà changé une couche je changeais
une seule fois pendant sa nnsa et après
j'ai sur voir comment stable à gauche
aussi ses bons essais pour un
chroniqueur il ya fabien lecoeuvre qui
nous a rejoints qui va prendre ce 30 cm
jean-michel je sais que c'est devenu ton
ami aujourd'hui oui c'était hier soir
encore il m'a appelé deux fois
aujourd'hui pour essayer de services
cloud dans l'émission va craquer surtout
on ne sait pas qu'on n'ait pas craquer
si vous ne saviez pas ce qu'est et qui
fait des petits boulots avant eux
on vous y avez vous étiez esthéticienne
esthéticienne assistante de photos on
est servi dans des fiches à jacques
ménard qui a toujours été riche
[Rires]
c'est quand je suis pas là ça manque un
peu de culture
non merci ça manque peut-être de culture
mais ça manque pas d'audience
[Rires]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]